hey youtubers it's Charlie this is going
to be my star wars rebels breaking ranks
review it's either like Episode four or
five the numbering is a little bit
messed up but I'm going to call it
episode five although technically I
think it's Episode four if you felt like
there was some story missing basically
what they did is they picked up in the
middle of the action and then cut away
to dialogue to explain what was going on
so think of this 22-minute episode is
like a 30 minute episode that they just
started eight minutes in careful for
spoilers if you haven't seen the episode
yet starting with top five moments
number five Ezra joins the Imperial
Academy they're still on Lothal which i
think is interesting you think the
Imperial Academy would be somewhere
bigger but the Empire is vast so of
course they have satellite schools in
the outer rim in terms of galactic
geography Lethal's pretty far away from
chorus on which is where we spent most
of the time during the prequels and
during the Clone Wars even though the
Clone Wars kind of traveled all around
as long as we get to see new locations
in loathe all like the Imperial Academy
in this episode I'm totally happy I
totally don't mind them sticking to that
planet a cursory examination of some of
the things that the Academy as well as
their security measures raised a few
issues that I'll just talk about as I go
through the video the reason he joined
the Academy was to get the decryption
card so they could find the location of
the shipment of Kyber crystals number
four is replaced by game setting
expectations low because Ezra is fairly
new it was fun to watch him try to be a
badass it's also a nice twist on the
idea of a Sith infiltrator he's like a
Jedi trainee infiltrator using the Force
to get information the friend that
stayed behind at the end to find his
sister I actually thought that Ezra was
going to try and control his mind
whenever he caught him in the middle of
the episode trying to break into the
office the kids stayed at the academy so
if he stays on and becomes a
stormtrooper arguably Ezra will have the
easiest time in the world controlling
his mind stormtroopers have the weakest
minds in the galaxy one of my first
stray observations Kallis does not like
getting unexpected packages he does not
like free things if they played the
scene for comedy he would have just been
like oh yes I will totally take this
free package that I definitely did not
order it does make you wonder what the
kid would have done if calais had
accepted the package that feels like day
one spy school stuff if you're going to
give someone a fake package bring a fake
package
so that you can give it to them number
three Ezra stormtrooper training this is
like a cross between the Star Trek
holodeck and Megaman it was fun to watch
Ezra run circles around everyone the
staff thought that it was fishy that he
was so good I thought they were going to
do something more with that and they did
tease the Inquisitor but he didn't show
up till the end I was kind of hoping
that he'd walk out on deck and see Ezra
and all hell would break loose I feel
like they made it just a little too easy
and they didn't really deliver on the
promise of it being super hard I mean
they electrify the platforms eventually
but there is no threat level to Ezra so
it feels like there's no stakes when you
hear stories about the Imperial Academy
usually it's a really grand really
fearsome thing and this just did not
feel like it maybe that's just a
flagship school so talking about in the
Core Worlds speaking about stormtroopers
too I know a lot of people are wondering
what's going on with the clone troopers
and with the normal troopers so at a
certain point in the Empire's growth
they stopped making new clone so there's
no clones anymore most of them died off
during the wars so now we're in the
initial days of them recruiting actual
people like they actually have to
recruit people again they can't just
magic up new forces overnight and it
even did take them a while to grow new
clones number two the big space battle
so we found out what happens when you
didn't need a ship that's in the process
of entering hyperspace I think the
explosion was extra big just because all
the Kyber crystals on board a lot of the
Star Wars visual media doesn't do a
really good job of explaining the
mechanics of hyperspace there's a couple
different ways to explain
faster-than-light travel there's
wormholes and then there's subspace and
I think subspace is the one that Star
Wars uses I try to hold Star Wars as
science against it it's not a show that
promises to explain a lot of things in
depth like that especially if it's an
animated show for children like rebels
is but if any of you have a really
detailed understanding of the mechanics
of Star Wars hyperspace just feel free
to write it below in the comments the
whole Kyber crystal plotline was one of
my complaints of the episode and that it
really didn't explain what was going on
very well like all the cutaways with the
exposition didn't really make up for the
fact that there were so many scenes
missing clearly this was a very
important mission Kyber crystals are
very big deal if you haven't read a lot
of the expanded material or the comics
that go into Kyber crystals there are
forced relic localized to very specific
places in the galaxy they increase the
power of force sensitive people at
thousand times over so if the Empire was
shipping them around the inquisitors
could use them to become much much more
powerful so if you cried a little bit
when they blew them all up they were
just trying to keep them out of the
hands of the enemy I suppose we can
forgive them that even though Canaan and
Ezra could have had a whole lot of fun
even with just one crystal note to self
next time before blowing up Kyber
crystals snag one in my number 1 moment
Ezra breaks out of the Academy best use
of an 80s t ever I think that was an
eight EST they say Walker but Walker is
just a general term for 80 80 80 st any
derivative type of transport like that
as much fun as it was watching them
crash their way out of the Academy
there's just a couple issues that I have
to raise first off the two commanders
worst commanders in the history of the
Academy while this is all going on
they're basically just standing there
yelling at people you think that one of
them would pick up a blaster and start
firing i'm guessing the Commandant is
working in the outer-rim territories as
an instructor because he's not that
great given the way things ended I would
think the Inquisitor is probably just
going to kill him after this episode to
say nothing of what's going to happen to
that kid that stayed behind to I don't
think that he's force-sensitive but the
Inquisitor is probably going to train
him he'll probably end up having to
fight Ezra later in the season either
that or he'll end up on a milk carton
like his sister as much as they shied
away from violence during the training
scenes the show does have a lot of
implied violence like for instance
whenever they were in the TIE fighter
battle they blew up all those ships
think about how many people were on
those ships then think about what the
Inquisitor is going to do to the
Commandant as well as that little kid
very dark stuff even if they don't show
it I feel like in not having the
characters address those deaths the show
is missing out there's a lot of extra
dramatic weight you can have killing
people is bad even if they are Imperials
let me know though what was your
favorite moment from the episode and
what do you think is going to happen to
Ezra's friend that the Inquisitor took
overall I gave the episode of B minus
just because I feel like it didn't have
any kind of dramatic tension it feels
like they're still using a lot of these
stories to set up bigger plots die for
instance the one they take into hiding
he's actually played by dante basco
who's Zuko from avatar the last
airbender so if there any last airbender
fans out there i'm sure you probably
pick that up
but I feel like they wouldn't cast
bigger actors for a lot of these side
roles if they weren't intending on
turning the characters into something
bigger I think my only real complaint
against the episode though was just how
easy it was for them to infiltrate the
Imperial Academy the episode really ends
up being just about putting your trust
in other people even though Jack
completely forgives Ezra for him
over halfway through the episode if this
were Ender's Game that would be like the
beginning of a blood feud I suppose
that's another reference you could draw
this episode is the Imperial Academy is
a little bit like Ender's Game all in
all it was an entertaining episode fun
to see the inside of Imperial Academy
little disappointing in the execution
next week as prophesied is a Hera Sabine
episode i think in one of my previous
videos i mentioned how they basically
had no screen time at all so surprise
surprise they get to headline an episode
together right now they're actually two
of the more interesting characters so
I'm actually pretty excited about that
be sure to subscribe to get my video
i'll be sure to post it next week there
are a couple shows that are on break
this week just because of midterm
elections but there's no flash no agents
of shield but there is arrow tomorrow so
i will be doing some bonus videos in the
next couple of days there is a marvel
special tonight it's called marvel 75th
anniversary so i'll be doing a video for
that too in the meantime you can click
here for my last star wars rebels video
and you can click here to learn all
about Marvel's phase 3 thank you so much
for watching so it's all high five and
I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]